quick question for all the women can you
all raise your hand real quick of all of
those women that have their hands raised
which one of you would rather be forced
to carry an unwanted pregnancy to term
time for the latest installment of
changed my mind I rationalized our
positions on controversial topics this
week is the fourth installment of our
recent abortion themed series of course
it's been all over the media given the
recent laws regarding late term abortion
it's dangerous to put any kind of
limitations or controls around that
because she in the end is the one
responsible for that and in those
circumstances and I don't think that
it's entirely fair to judge them a fetus
is literally a parasite like it is
sucking the life from a mother yeah
every single day like that literally
what happened
that's not even not a mother I'm
guessing
[Music]
there's no point in wondering when it
comes to women's rights with respect to
their reproduction I think you should
leave it to women this is about a
woman's right to choose and you as a man
should not have a single say in that as
per usual let me know what you think by
sounding off in the comment section
below I'll I'll try on this topic I was
a little surprised by how extreme most
people's positions were on the issue
here see for yourself
wasn't it Mitch Mitch Steven nice to
meet you gonna meet I have no idea
whether you're familiar or not with the
segment that we do but it's basically an
opportunity to rationalize one's
position I'm pro-life and all that that
would encompass here I guess you'd
probably understand where I line up but
if you disagree with me things anything
wrong with my position you're more than
welcome to change my mind I do think
there's a lot wrong with your position
if you're going to try to tell more than
half the world's population more than
half of America's population that they
are not allowed to decide to do with
their bodies what they want to do but a
dead body if they're not an organ donor
they're not gonna get harvested for
organ donation then I think that's
really messed up and frankly I think
that women should have the option
legally and otherwise to be able to get
an abortion if they want to okay there
are a few presumptions there no I would
never tell 50 percent of America as you
put it about half of America what they
can and can't do with their own bodies
but that's exactly what the pro-life
argument is you're going to make
abortions illegal which then is going to
force the women of America to either
find a way to get an illegal abortion
which has done host of problems both
medical legal etc as abortion does abort
as safe abortion doesn't hurt those what
what what what what what things are
medically wrong with a medical abortion
for the baby being killed okay I'm not
talking about the baby why not because
the simple fact of the matter is is the
baby is not
an autonomous living being really
helpful because it cannot fend for
itself
okay so would a two month old baby not
being autonomous human being we're not
talking about a two month old baby we're
talking about a fetus so no I'm using
your definition you said cannot fend for
itself so it's fending for itself the
standard of what constitutes a human
being no okay so what constitutes a
human being the fact that it is born
okay so what makes the difference
between being and not a human being is
seven inches about the birth canal yeah
okay so you would be okay with abortion
all the way up to nine months in certain
Sikkim circumstances yeah okay
what do you mean in certain certain
circumstance uh if the birth would be
fatal to either the mother or the fetus
then I do think that abortion should be
legal oh sure let's say if the birth
wouldn't kill the mother no I don't know
any major pro-life advocates who
wouldn't agree with that yeah I've met
quite a few actually no I have yet to
meet one so maybe you can give me your
rolodex but I certainly would say if
you're looking at the direct a direct
threat to the life of the mother yes I
understand that okay whatever but let me
say if it sounds mean like that doesn't
really matter because you would support
abortion
regardless yes okay so why bring it up
because people especially in America
have the freedom to make choices and
right now the and right now the pro-life
argument is trying to infringe upon one
of the choices and quick question for
all the women can you all raise your
hand real quick seriously seriously
I don't care if it's 101 of all of those
women that have their hands raised which
one of you would rather be forced to
carry an unwanted pregnancy to term on
second I appreciate I appreciate it I
really do appreciate it but I also want
to continue with this thank you very
much I appreciate your passion that's
the danger of using mob rule as your
moral compass
sometimes you don't like how it turns
out and I could have actually told you
the first thing I've been a pro-life
woman here a couple of things
a couple of things I want to clarify I
would never tell a woman what she can
and can't do with her own body okay now
what I am doing okay that's not what she
is doing and I would never force a woman
to carry a gun
okay okay but that's exactly what the
pro-life stance is what's not so what a
what about the pro-life argument and
pro-life laws and regulations and all
that is going to allow women the choice
okay because that's the whole basis of
the pro-choice argument right yeah
that's a false premise what laws would
allow the choice to kill another human
being but it's not a human being
oh it is a human being well how do you
define a man being you said fend for
itself that's not a consistent yeah and
that and that seven inches of birth
canal as you said well you said you
didn't agree earlier nothing for itself
so in other words no not until no it's
not a living human being until it
crosses that birth canal okay why why
because it's still in the womb it is
still a fetus so well on a second so
we're talking about right now a nine
month old baby let's say eight month old
right it's not a baby in fact it's not a
baby until it's born so the only
difference right now I'm using a nine
month isn't it let's pick an eight month
old okay eight months inside the womb
eight months outside of them
one is a life and one is not yeah okay
so what determines human life is
location if a woman has an
eight-month-old fetus versus an 8 month
old child that is a huge difference
because one is inside the woman one is
outside the only difference is let's
call it geographical location but it's
not the same as geographical location
okay it's a location inside of when
we're outside a woman but you're
oversimplifying it you're trying to
understand I'm okay why is one of life
and one is not because the fetus itself
is wholly and totally dependent upon the
mother that is attached to via umbilical
cord sure right wholly dependent very
much Blandon ja I can eight month old
born born
however the a month old child the
infant's at that point that's the
important distinction fetus versus
infant is your important distinction I
don't think it's a consistent one but
continue is the fact that a fetus which
has not been born yet
and an infant's which has been born in
my opinion it shouldn't matter whether
or not the mother wants to keep it or
not
whether it's but I owners I guess I'm
not following you
why does that determine the value of
human life is it because you don't
believe you don't believe it's a human
being because you believe it's a part of
the mother yes okay so you don't believe
that's it you don't believe that that is
a separate human being you believe it's
effectively a part of the mother yes
because up until the point okay that it
is outside of the mother okay whether
it's c-section birth whatever then at
that point it becomes its own okay
living human being okay I'm trying to
still dependent upon other people
because it is infinite so what doesn't
necessarily need to be the mother
biological mother that is still hooked
up to the Imboden defense so I want to
make sure that I'm understanding your
reasoning for why it is a baby outside
versus inside the womb even though it's
the same age you are saying that
location and that determines whether
it's a human life because in fact when
it's inside the womb
it is not a separate human being it as a
part of the mother yes okay I've not
misrepresented you there I understand
you correctly yeah okay so an eighth one
eight month old baby inside of the
mother in unfold a mental 8 month old
fetus
it's not a person inside the mother okay
how many feet is a mom half sari how
many feet does the mother have two not
four not four how many fingers does she
have it 10 not 20 no infants are likened
to at the part of the mother yeah yeah
yeah part of the mother the mother would
have 20 fingers 20 toes forearm yeah so
the boy doesn't mother have the penis
you're you're trying to detract from the
fact that no I'm trying no no no no yeah
so effectively it is a parasitic
relationship between a fetus and a woman
the parasite parasite is a being that is
wholly and totally dependent upon its
host it's actually not the definition
apparently okay so what's the definition
of a parasite mr. Webster
I appreciate the presumption no actually
because by your definition a fully born
child would be a parasite because
they're entirely dependent on somebody a
good example that for example with
sharks or amaura's or inconsiderate
parasites even though they are dependent
upon the food that they were okay so the
reason here is because it actually does
so at the cost of its host at the host
of the healthcare of the host at the
cost of the actual ability often killing
the host that's what a parasite is and
parasites don't necessarily even have to
be inside the body by the way they can
be on or if yeah we're no medical
literature would refer to a baby growing
in a woman's body as a pair
that's an opinion okay so Ally opinion
it's your opinion but it's also your
opinion that it is a part of the woman's
body but that doesn't seem to understand
how you sort of juxtapose that next to
you but the woman only has two feet yeah
and one only has 20 so what are those
fingers on that baby
there's letting the penis who does it
belong to it it belongs to the fetus
which we just said it does have body and
autonomy from the mother at this point
it is not a part of the mother no it is
a part of mother because my attached to
the mother does the mother have a penis
no because the fetus is a parasite
because the fetus is a parasite yes okay
I'm just trying to follow your logic
trail here because before you said it
was in fact a part of the mother it is
that was what it interesting it's a
parasite it why can't it be both you
know I suppose it could be both okay so
it's a parasitic part of the mother yes
so the penis belongs to a parasite or
the arms and the legs and the feet and
the functioning brain in the central
nervous system and the ability to
understand and recognize its mother's
voice belongs to a parasite fetus that
is in the mother and is not human life
yes and that is why we have the right to
kill it
yes okay all the way up until birth it
like I said before if it is if it is
going to be a fatality to either the
baby at that point the infants or the
mother
yeah well done we don't discuss because
you don't care anyway that's a very very
strong assumption to make
well you said earlier that you would
support abortion regardless sorry yes
okay so then why bring up whether it's a
threat of the health to the mother
because no medical professional is going
to make a late-term abortion unless it's
going to be a fatality to either the
mother or the fetus that's not true it
happens all the time
name one case where that's happened 10
to 12 thousand a year 1.6 percent one
point three to one point six percent of
about a million abortions each year as a
matter of fact you can go right now
right now watch a video that we take in
an abortion clinic on Tuesday where they
performed an abortion the 32 week old
baby no questions asked okay and happens
all okay but if you disagree with that
yeah you do 2/3 with that yeah because
you no no no I I disagree with your
stance on it because you don't know what
that woman's lit like you you don't know
that woman's life you don't know that
woman you don't know what the
circumstances are you don't know any I
do matter do you yeah I do you know her
personally
I know exactly what our circumstances
are because she told them to us yeah she
was a woman who had two children already
at 6 and a 9 year old and the the
youngest of which was now being sent off
to kindergarten and she didn't want to
go through the mommy face again
that's how no time for herself because
she went in and they provided a 32 week
old abortion no questions asked that
happens late term abortions 10 to 12
thousand a year ok so so you want to
make sure could you jump around as to
what's permissible and what's not my
line of logic here is whether you like
it or not it is consistent along with
the lady there who responded to you a
unique new genetic code is created at
conception
okay right it sounds like you're saying
whether it's in whether it's out
depending on how how the mother feels
about the baby it's circumstantial it's
just a logically consistent way to
justify killing another life okay well
you're an un situation so question okay
the situation I just described for you
can go watch it right now yeah we cannot
go to the extreme examples to make a
point because if I were to say if I were
to say hey rape incest let's allow
abortions and say but on the other on
the other side of the coin would you be
okay with making it illegal to perform
other abortions you ain't saying you
wouldn't say so so might bring it up you
bring up an extreme example that you
don't care about you support abortion
all the way up until birth no matter
what thank you very much I appreciate
[Music]
would you want to come for just two
seconds to kind of describe why you
we usually it's mostly people who
disagree but we don't usually do this
that changed my mind but because this
young lady was so passionate and because
her opinion would seem so unpopular I
wanted to hear what she had to say hear
for yourself what's your name my name is
Glenn Elise Glenn Elise when Elise all
right Glenn Elise we can't take super
long because usually we try to give the
right-of-way to people who disagree but
and it right after you did it you
appreciate you don't have to be
apologetic but he talks to the audience
our previous speaker and said how many
women here would want to be forced to
carry that baby to pregnancy and you
said I would because it's a living being
and you shouted it everyone here heard
you I think we heard you on our shotgun
mics aim the other direction why such a
visceral reaction there because I have
I've experienced with several family
members and several friends throughout
high school that had to go through that
issue and it's the simple fact that it's
it has brain activity the baby is it
like legally doctors are like okay
you're pregnant cuz they go for they
look for a heartbeat and they look for
brain activity so that's the first sign
of human life from a non-religious
standpoint and then also I should for
people who it was in the context of him
talking about late term abortions as
well right yeah yeah so also it's just
even there's legal things that say that
whenever the mother doesn't want it we
learned in school that if the father
wants it
you can't abort the baby because it's
his baby too yeah so it's like it's not
just like the mother's choice because it
takes it takes two to tango it takes two
to make a living being and also there's
adoption there are people who cannot
have babies who want children they want
the opportunity to teach someone what
they have to teach them in their life
and they can't do it biologically so
they adopt children if you don't want
your baby you can give it to somebody
who wants to take care of it I have
family members who can't have children
and they want children so bad and let me
ask you this because um I was kind of
curious he framed it in a way we said
would you want to be forced to carry a
baby to term even the fact that you
reacted so passionately as passionately
as you did makes me think that you don't
see it as being forced to carry a baby
no it's it's not a lot of my venomous
also has to do with my religion because
I'm a Christian good but um but because
this is about politics I'm trying very
hard not to put my religion in - no I
understand I appreciate that okay so the
point the point that I'm making is that
we're often told that if someone is a
victim of a horrible crime like rape
right right and if we say well then you
still probably shouldn't abort that baby
it's like forcing women to carry it
that's whereas all we're doing is
forbidding someone from killing another
person right it's not it and it can be a
traumatic experience I have experienced
things like of that nature and it's it
is traumatic it's horrible and but it's
still not it's not you you're carrying
this is where my religion comes into it
it's like God gave you that baby right
on purpose he knew that baby before it
was even in your stomach he had this
plan from the beginning that's just how
it works
so that's another reason that I'm just
like it's not your choice after that I
appreciate it I boil it what I
appreciate most was obvious there was
kind of some white knighting going on
like hey women don't you all agree with
me I'm on your side yeah seems to me
like you're a little
more empathetic to a life that could be
growing inside of you and I just it was
very touching to see you respond again
you know we want to keep it civil and
not yet so much worried it was just you
just seemed so arrogant about it made me
come in well thank you being here thank
you so much I appreciate it thank you it
was a refreshing change of pace now back
to your regularly scheduled program
[Applause]
Maddie we actually have a lovely lady
who works for us today Maddie yeah I was
told she's vicious we must all be very
special yes she's very quiet but we all
suspect that she's a heroin dealer I
really like you she she's from the hills
of Missouri so we have no idea what
she's up to dig the shoes okay Maddie so
I'm pro-life a sort of asserted my
position here yes quite a few times I
really what this is about is hopefully
not a shouting [ __ ] it's about the
ability to rationalize one's own
position and can I just say first some
of the men over there wanted me to speak
up louder so everybody could hear but I
don't want to mess with your audio if I
speak louder will it mess with your
mouth you're fine you're fine okay cool
we're actually having a girl on audio
okay so yeah and you can also speak
louder if you want that's okay I don't
want it I don't want to be accused of I
don't know mansplaining man yelling
there's a new man something may
interrupting I heard recently oh wow I
don't know that's why I made that up I
made that I'm talking about an
interrupting thing but I want it to
catch on you can pass along so I am
pro-life if you disagree with my
position or you disagree with the
pro-life position you are more than
welcome to change my mind okay where do
you think that pro-life and pro-choice
arguments stem from like what do you
think it is the base argument the base
disagreement that people have it's
actually a very good question where's
the fork in the road yeah so what what
is what is
yeah the beginning fork in the road that
makes people really kind of take up arms
and get mad I think it's what
constitutes a human life okay our life
beginning so yeah
I think it's and I think as a matter of
fact that's the most important question
answer I think it's the only question
that needs to be answered
otherwise the rest of it is really one
big giant true and of course as a
pro-life person
life begins scientifically at conception
okay I also think that that's something
that you believe strongly you know like
that's what you believe I don't think
that I'm gonna be able to change your
mind on that okay that is the stemming
point of where your beliefs come from
let me ask this why would you disagree
why would I disagree yeah just because I
don't believe that like human life
starts at conception you know what I
actually went all four years to a
Catholic High School and I studied
intently I studied the New Testament the
Old Testament the Catholic catechism as
well as certain letters written by
different saints and apostles and I did
learn a lot about like abstinence and
family planning and and life at birth I
actually disagree with that nowadays not
life at birth sorry guys live at
conception
right but I disagree with that nowadays
but I do I do a good bit about it and I
understand alright he's more than
welcome to join in afterward if he wants
[Applause]
now this is the point where we were
rudely interrupted by a screeching
protester you can see that entire
confrontations in the video at the link
below
but for this let's go back to Magda I do
appreciate that even though you disagree
with me you pulled a wonderful prank by
sending me to that unstable gentleman
there well you know what really struck
me was he just said I don't want to talk
I'm just here to shut down your bull and
took pride and simply shutting down a
conversation and I would imagine that
you probably line up more left than I do
but it doesn't seem like you're somebody
who would see virtue and shutting down
conversation know everything important
has been first conversed about right
that's the first step to learning and
the first step to accepting change is to
talk about things right I appreciate
that
would you consider that kind of a fork
in the road between yourself and sort of
the modern progressive left because what
he just did that's not a typical in my
experience these days you know what I
think that also appears in more extreme
right sections as well I think anybody
who's very very offended by people
attacking their personal beliefs or
people who may take things personally
have the tendency to not want to
consider different points of views as
well as wanting to make themselves feel
better this is race okay I know the
reason I says because I'm about as far
right as you can get and not how the
media labels far-right you don't not see
spenta mainyu libertarian conservatives
generally speaking we believe in more
speech not less I would say that today
as it relates to free speech on campus
and as it relates to speech whether I
mean take your pick on any platform it
does seem to be exclusively coming from
the left using a bully technic to shut
people down and that's really I'm not
I'm saying I appreciate that you're not
that way
but I do wonder if for a lot of liberals
on college campus now who maybe they
consider themselves sort of classical
liberals I would say critical thinking
sort of classical liberal that's how you
appear to me at least in the way you
present yourself if you find it grating
to have people like that kind of setting
that the tone
temperature on campus well I would just
like to say he does not represent all of
UNT okay you know there are so many
people here with different opinions with
different beliefs that man is not the
spokesperson for UNT but what she knew
would be funny that's why she was where
yeah he called ben shapiro odd not see
he's like I know Ben is like as jewy as
they get I mean not Jewish like he's
crossover that they're you know there's
the line of Jewish and jewy and like
look behind you that's the line he's so
jewy good friend of mine I can say this
all right so I'm pro-life I can't
remember where we were we might just
have to start this from the top you you
asked I guess before where the the
disagreement what do you think the
mental screaming occurs right is that
what we were the definition of what is
human right and and and I posited that
life begins at conception and the reason
for this I truly see it as the only
consistent line to draw because that is
when a new unique human genetic code is
created completely autonomous one mother
from the father it's not the same as
sperm it sounds the same as an egg we
had a guy come here and say well there's
no difference between that that fetus
and you scraping off dead skin cells it
is it's entirely different DNA I don't
see any other line that can be drawn
that is intellectually consistently so
that's what I believe what what do you
believe constitutes a human life or do
you believe life begins you know what I
don't think that that's something I'm a
big believer in science and I think that
we should look to science for certain
ethical issues about things such as
learning about the science of skin color
it has nothing to do with your organs or
anything like that it's all about just
adaptation to UV radiation so I think
that science is a way to go and I also
believe in the consideration of
suffering of living organisms every
living organism so I think that this is
just my personal opinion I do as a woman
up here I'm not the spokes man for every
woman spokeswoman for every woman I'm
not lots of different women lots of
different women of color lots of
different white women especially like on
UNT campuses and in Texas have different
opinions in mind I appreciate that
don't
no I appreciate that because there was a
guy I actually kind of came up here
earlier the white knights and all the
women raise your hand who would want to
be forced to carry a baby from rape and
she yelled she's like well I'm not being
forced as just not letting you kill the
baby and then he sort of we wasn't very
comfortable and he left soon after so
I'm only speaking for myself yeah if
you're always speaking for yourself so
where do you believe life begins or
what's your I guess your view your
worldview on a board my worldview is
more centered around suffering and I
don't believe in the suffering of living
organisms of sentient beings and so I
think the consideration of suffering is
really important I think that the
consideration of the suffering of a
being that may be inside you is also
important but the thing is I believe
that the most qualified people to sit
here and to talk about this do not want
to sit here and talk about this women
who have had abortions or women who are
pregnant and thinking of getting
abortions or any women that has had to
make that choice or think about that
choice is a person who I think should be
up here explaining about the first-hand
experiences the emotions they go through
what the family members say because
there's lots of things that we don't
consider about abortion and I think that
if we think that women don't obsess over
this question that's a false conclusion
that is a huge suspicion a woman has to
make in her life as she chooses to I
think in some instance you're correct in
some instances my mouth is called out
you're correct in some you're not we had
a woman who sat down to inhabit abortion
and frankly hadn't given it much
consideration as to where life begins
we've had men sit down I would ask you
this so but I know you've talked about
how your worldview centers on suffering
and I can appreciate that but why do you
believe for example I would assume that
applies probably to animals as well oh
yeah I'm trying to go vegan guys
he's being very respectful so you
obviously would want to minimize
suffering okay do you believe that you
are less qualified to talk about that
issue than a man I would actually say
that I'm probably more qualified well
okay well let's let's make sure that we
have the proper definition of man okay
the person with the vagina who can get
pregnant you know I'm fertile I can't
get pregnant some women can't get
pregnant no - yeah sure whatever
you know I I believe in that I don't
would you say that only farmers should
have opinions on the suffering of
animals no but I do think farmers have
more direct experience with the
suffering of animals and maybe therefore
their opinion should be taken a little
more seriously than people who've never
has seen an animal more farmers who
advocate for more suffering of animals
in yourself should have the animal
farmers you don't have that opinion so I
think understand where I'm going here I
don't understand why a woman or
particularly a woman who's had an
abortion would be supremely qualified to
discuss an issue if in fact it relates
to the killing of another human being
I'm not saying supremely qualified I'm
saying more qualified so by that I mean
somebody who has a little more
experience or education about it I would
disagree I sit for the same reason I
think you are just as qualified you are
equally as qualified as any man here or
any other woman here a person of color
named the race gender orientation on
murder on assault on battery I don't
think it matters if you've committed it
or not or even if you've been the victim
of it or not I think what is morally
correct as an absolute certainly as it
relates to the physical harm of another
human being against their will so we are
told us a lot and I think we even had
someone say say you know if you don't
have a vagina
can't have an opinion I don't agree I
don't understand how that changes the
fundamental estimate of what abortion is
is it the ending the killing of another
human life or not and like you said
that's where the fork in the road starts
and I think that everything else is
negated if we don't come to a clear
definition as to what that is you're
right and I think like for me personally
as I'm going to say again for like the
third time I think we should probably
look a little bit to science for that as
well okay and I think that religion has
a really big influence on what we
consider live and what we consider
valuable but I have a question for you
do you think in any way at all possible
you know maybe now or historically that
the definition of life has been
influenced by the fact that it's women
who carry this life so maybe perhaps
women historically who've been oppressed
have not had the right to choose what
happens to the source and the right to
choose what happens to this life oh sure
wouldn't have been forcibly sterilized
well yes and I would say even more than
that people women have been socially
engineered or manipulated to place
different values on that baby you know
throughout history I mean you've seen
that you know with Jewish women and Nazi
Germany so well the reason because we
actually hear better once in a [ __ ] s
that's kind of a promise this isn't a
harvey weinstein thing I can pull it
away from you but I don't for example
Nazis placed a different value on the
babies in the womb of Jewish women in
North Korean internment camps random
people who are dissidents they force
abortion is right so it's not only
people being forcefully sterilized but
there have been different values set
upon different kinds of we often based
are the babies inside of women based on
race ethnicity you know or political
worldview I agree that's terrible I
think we both agree that that's
historically been true and it's terrible
and that's also I have such a problem
with the abortion bill in the United
States because it's stems from a
eugenics movement from martyr Sanger
with Planned Parenthood setting up
abortion clinics in impoverished areas
in order to try and eradicate the
country of black Americans I don't know
much about that that's something that I
that I'm not very educated in okay would
you look it up after this no Margaret
Sanger she's not
Planned Parenthood and she had disdain
for black tea you know what women of
color have been historically exploited
more than any other group in America my
personal belief and from the things that
I've learned so I'm really not realized
that organizations who claim to help
women have historically exploited them
that's not surprising to me just because
it's Planned Parenthood though I don't
think he means anything in particular in
industries all over the world had
exploited women beauty industries health
industries clothing yeah but
specifically targeting areas so that
women of color kill their babies to try
and reduce their population I would say
is a little bit more perverse and
telling someone they should use this
kind of lip gloss to look like Claudia
Schiffer and are we sure that it's to
reduce they are we sure that it's some
sort of genetic you know ethnic
cleansing yes Margaret Sanger was a
eugenicist okay
so you're saying you're saying nowadays
that's for sure the roots of Planned
Parenthood and the slave funding
disproportionately set up in areas where
your women of color they would argue
that due to poverty and that they're
there to help them that's not the
history of the company but III think we
both agree that being said whatever
value society places on something
doesn't change what it is for example I
think we both agree I don't agree with
that I think that ideas can be just as
impactful as actions I think that the
ideas that we've been raised with can
definitely influence what we do and the
people that we meet and how we treat I
agree with you but I don't thing that
necessarily means it's right so for
example slavery good or bad
okay we both agree these are in trick
questions right yeah but it was legal it
still is legal all across the world so
yeah we shouldn't go by like that's a
you know very common mistake do not go
by legality legality something is you
know as what is more exactly what I said
it to say that because it's a different
societies a place different values so we
can't necessarily go by right now we're
talking about abortion right there is
the the abortion survivors born alive
Protection Act every single major
Democratic candidate for president
loaded against and this is babies who
survived abortions
this bill would just require that
doctors provide them with the same
medical care to babies delivered that
didn't survive abortions Elizabeth
Warren Bernie Sanders Kamala Harris Cory
Booker they all voted against this and
we're talking about abortion many states
I think we're talking about well beyond
the point where it might even be a
debate when you're talking about we're
even talking about babies that are
entirely valuable upsetting their people
for a regular basis and that's legal it
doesn't change the morality of the
action and that's why I think it is
fundamental to determine what a human
life is and where that begins and as
you've said we start with science and I
hope you understand for me I know you
that you said went to a Catholic school
yeah I am a Christian but I haven't
brought any of that into this
conversation yeah
scientifically the moment of conception
is when there's an entirely different
genetic code that determines everything
you know hair color eye color height
sense of smell athletic ability is
created at conception science tells us
that is a new unique human being and I
don't think that we ever have the right
to kill another human life I think that
that's your interpretation of science I
definitely believe that you know stem
cells have the potential to turn into
any sort of specific specialized tissue
and that you're right they they it is a
seed that has the potential to become a
new person reason to see but that's the
exhibit for example I don't see I don't
see sperm killing a sperm the same as
abortion otherwise you know when I was a
teenager I would be committing mass
genocide like
that's what Catholics believe yeah I
don't so the point is is very different
a fertilized egg cell is entirely been
from an egg and a sperm that's the
science I want to make sure that I'm not
misunderstood here I don't think that
because it's a potential necessarily
human being this is a unique genetic
code that has been performed that
determines what kind of a human being it
will be that does not happen until the
moment of conception so do you believe
that then genetics is what makes us
human that a that it's our special gene
code the special Homo Sapien gene code
is what makes us funny sapiens well I
believe that first off human beings give
birth to human babies right so we know
that when that genetic code is
established it's not going to be a fish
it's not going to be a dog it's going to
be a human being
and that is the moment where exactly
what kind of a human being is determined
and I just don't think that we have the
right to intervene and terminate kill
back humanity that's why that's why I
think it's the only logically consistent
line I think we would both agree
viability is not really consistent line
because some babies are viable at
different times depending where they are
depending at what point in history
location whether it's inside the womb or
outside the womb I don't think that a
baby that's at nine months five seconds
before it leaves the womb is less of a
human being and the baby that leaves the
womb for me the only logical one the
only consistently logic the only
logically consistent line get a little
cold here yeah it is yeah I've been out
here a few hours now is conception
scientifically in the book where where
would you say life begins or what
constitutes a human life
well I'm a big hippie so huh far cry
from the modern leftist whose shout
people down I'm a big ol hippie so my
definition of life and what it is to be
alive I guess would have to would you
consider a bacteria alive even though
it's not sentient you know what what
what sorts of values do we ascribe to
normal human life human life I know only
human life is a return on your time an
abortion bacteria is not the same as a
human being
listen you know what I I don't know okay
I don't know when human life starts but
I think it's important we should know
when suffering starts okay so would you
draw the line at suffering yes I think
that that's what but the thing is you
don't know yet so I don't want to press
you all so let's not overlook context
here
III am pro-life because I really want to
represent for the young women and all
those women who have had been sexually
assaulted and who've gotten pregnant I
really believe that young women should
have a choice like a 13 year old girl
who gets raped by her uncle she should
have a choice of whether this is going
to affect her for her whole life or
whether this is something that could be
taken care of in private well let me ask
you this because we've had this happen a
lot today so let's allow exceptions and
people bring up a radical exception to
the rule to try and justify them yeah so
let's say we make exemptions for rape
and incest okay
let's say I agree with you on that then
would you agree that all other abortions
should be I think it's so contextual I
say bringing up an extreme example when
the vast majority of abortions are not
are not permitted because of that
because of rape princess the vast
majority of abortions are simply simply
performed because and I think that
that's okay I think that it's okay as
long as there's no suffering yeah but
the thing is how are we supposed to know
when suffering starts well that's where
we go to science it's pretty clear yeah
but you know what I do endorse the
abortion bills that are being proposed
and being passed because even though if
I don't believe it's perfect I think
that it may be a step in the right
direction how do you mean abortion bills
that prevent the late term abortions or
you support the abortion bills that
further the line of word abortion to be
performed
I guess further the line okay well this
this is important I'm talking about
suffering where then would you want us
to be able to perform an abortion where
do you think there should be a line
drawn I'm not you know I'm not a doctor
I don't know about this okay well I can
tell you this suffering starts here okay
okay is it but this or the portions are
poor for just you're just telling me
this has like one person to another
person okay let's assume I'm not lying
okay let's assume that this is like
scientifically credible which it
probably is you think you guys suffering
begins it is more brain development
okay so suffering begins here abortions
are being performed all the way to here
so when you say you support bills being
proposed the reason I asked is because
here's a bill right here the survived
abortion and survivors I keep forgetting
the name it's like infant protection
abortion survivors Act I believe is the
entire it's a whole mouthful sorry my
hands are really cold here if you want
to look through that this is proposing
this was opposed by every major
Democratic candidate that would simply
require doctors to provide the same
medical care it's of babies who have
survived abortions these are babies that
are out of the birth canal they are
living and doctors would simply be
required to provide them sane medical
cares of other babies every major
Democratic candidate as as a
self-professed hippie who's against
suffering I'm not a Democrat though I'm
not a liberal and I'm not progressive I
don't believe in okay labeling I believe
in contextual things I think that it's
so hard to ascribe yourself to a party I
also think that I bring it up because
you just mentioned bills for a deadline
and I'm saying the line is here here's
the line and now we're even saying law
second can we at least have a line after
the baby's born survives an abortion
where the doctors just required to give
the same amount of care like Jason and
occurred them and I juice us because
only Democrats would want to further
that line no you don't have to protect
that baby if it's born alive if you
intended to have an abortion so when you
say you support the laws that further
that line I'm telling you the line in
Texas it's here you can see right that's
the line in Texas this is the line in
Colorado
so where would it be I think that this
life line should be accessible to young
women I think I just think that line
where this line the most I think they so
always should have yes should should
have access
okay well that's one but just don't say
that you it's not consistent suffering
of people who are already alive
I do i prioritize suffering of people
who I recognize as already living which
I guess you could say is it technically
a bias of what is life and what is
considered life I think I think it's a
very skewed view of suffering listen
that's right
look it I want you to look at this for
me yeah this baby that you just said is
okay to abort they are going to chop off
its arms and legs and jam forceps in its
head and it will be fully capable of
feeling pain and if you are comparing
that to the suffering of a mother who
doesn't want to bring it to turn because
it might inconvenience her I think it's
a very skewed view as to what suffering
is I am going to side what's not killing
this baby I'm not talking about one
mother I'm talking about all mothers
what I'm talking about all women who
have been put in situations that was not
their fault that they got victimized in
situations that are really situations
that can change your life and how you
think of yourself and how you look at
yourself in the mirror and I just want
these options open to women well
eliminate if we eliminate those
scenarios rape incest right we limit
those scenarios
you did say abortion Oh web here for for
people who can't see if it's available
to one person because well actually
that's not true but I think there was a
law that was passed it would be hard to
just separate certain people that could
and could not allow we just did actually
a video I would recommend you watch it
to get the chance we went to a Colorado
abortion a late-term abortion clinic who
was go in and show people what an
abortion is and a woman had an abortion
at 32 weeks that's eight months of
discussion want the baby no questions
they didn't ask about rape or incest I
told you I do I prioritize the suffering
well no you're not prioritizing
something you're prioritizing the
convenience of a mother over the killing
room a because come on let's be honest
here you and I neither one of us are
denying
that is a humanoid well we don't know
that woman personally we don't know her
life and we don't know if she actually
we are talking about a specific woman
talking metastatic woman in a rate of 10
to 12 thousand abortions per you I don't
want to talk about specifically not
ending a human life you just said you'd
be okay that's we both enough can we
both agree that's ending a human life at
that point yeah you know what I think so
and that baby will suffer scientific
there's no debate about the sign
typically you're most likely to be you
are prioritizing and again the vast
majority of abortion cases particularly
late term abortion cases are not I'm
saying this the vast majority of
abortions aren't late term abortions no
no no no what I'm saying the vast
majority of abortions are not performed
at a medical necessity or gonna rape or
incest how many could you tell me a
statistic on how many women get
abortions from 27 to 40 weeks yeah well
like what says it's a late term
abortions in about 1.3 to 1.6 depending
on who you ask depending which
statistics you use that's 10 to 12,000
abortions per year in this period that
are not medically necessary okay I can
as someone who not only about it and I
do place human life is more valuable
than animal life I'm gonna be honest
about that but as someone who does not
believe that a human being has the right
to physically harm another human being
oh I don't believe but we both agree
that's a human being and they're harming
them I don't think it's justifiable so I
look I appreciate you sitting down and I
appreciate a the time I think that some
of your views or maybe not necessarily
consistent with what you think them to
be you know or against I'm 20 I'm still
figuring myself out I appreciate it I
don't think that I'm gonna ever believe
what you believe or support what you
support but that's okay there's so many
different people in the world with all
different opinions and I would I would
hope that you can appreciate that as
someone who does believe for example
that this 34 week old baby of the human
life and capable of feeling pain as the
sense that it's my duty to go and try
and educate people and dirty I can to
save those lives just as I'm sure you do
for animals
and you know that that's a that's an
admirable reason to go do things and
yeah free speech exercise your free
speech and then scream at anyone or try
and shut them yeah there's nobody
screaming or anything so that's great
well no there was but we he's gone now
alright well thank you so much man
[Music]
with peanuts plain by the way if you
want to see more installments I've
changed my mind or the kind of content
that traditional media just can't create
support the show by joining mug club
ladder with CARICOM / mug Club
ninety-nine dollars annually 69 for
veteran students or active military you
get the full daily show as well the
catalog of other content and we
appreciate it on with the show
Lysander
but I'm pro-life across the board if
there's anything there that you disagree
with or where you think I'm wrong you're
more than welcome to change my mind okay
we're um why do you believe in pro-life
well my pro-life yeah just because I
don't believe that a human being has the
right to take the life of another human
being against their will at any point
okay now are you what's your position
I believe until a baby takes its first
breath after it's been born then it is
alive okay yeah you mean until er you
mean after it's taken its first breath
after it's like once it breathes in air
okay after it's gotten out of like the
womb and it has released all of the
fluids that are in their lungs okay
then I think it's alive okay so before
that it's not a life I don't believe so
okay so that would be all the way up
until nine months really up until a
seven-month seven-inch travel through
the birth canal
any time it has to be a like-for-like
any time it has to be removed due to
birth complications from c-section or
any time it is born naturally it has any
um any complications where it has to be
born prematurely then and it actually is
still alive after that process and
breathes I believe it is alive okay
so you're talking about birth
complications why does that matter it
sounds like you're okay with aborting
babies whether their birth complications
are not all the way up until nine months
correct am I mistaken um I believe you
can if the parent or basically just a
parent is willing to have that make that
choice by themselves and does not
believe that child will either they
can't take care of it or they or that
child will not be living in a suitable
environment
it sure a couple of things I know he
said parent not parents if a single
mother either through a violent
altercation rape in this case or a well
I want to bring up a really extreme very
rare example to prove a point on the
general rule and and I I don't think
it's necessarily productive because it
sounds to me like you don't care so
let's say I were to say okay yes to all
abortions from rape incest or forcible
acts of violence would you be against
all other forms of abortions if I say
sure abortions for any cases of rape and
incest would you be against all other
abortions like all other cases that are
not rape and incest yeah you would be
against all the other abortions Minnie
you would be for them yes okay so then
why bring it up because it is an
instance which but it doesn't matter you
support it anyway you support it right
you set up until the baby takes its
first breath and it's outside of the
womb the mom can abort it for any reason
regardless of rape or incest yes correct
yeah okay so um I guess my question to
you is what makes that not a human life
let's say at 8 months and 25 days versus
being a human life by your definition
it's just that first breath outside of
the womb because anything inside the
womb is being controlled by natural
instinct of heartbeat blood flow all the
brain uh like electrical signals in the
brain is literally just testing itself
any time you feel it that's inaccurate
it has to you know up until nine months
the idea that it's just testing itself
in a testing phase that's that's not
accurate
when you have babies that are born at 25
weeks the earliest I think is twenty-one
weeks so you're talking about aborting
fully viable babies because the mother
wants to as long as it hasn't taken that
first breath but I do we need to make
sure that we both understand what you're
talking about here you're not talking
about a clump of cells that is testing
brainwave activity you're talking about
a fully functional human being
so my question I guess to you is what
constitutes a human being right it seems
like you're okay with
killing all the way up until birth canal
alright um what defines personhood why
is it okay to do that what do you mean
by that you're taking the life of
another human being
mm-hmm why is that okay or maybe a
mistaken how do you define a human being
do not believe that it's a human being
because it hasn't breathed air it hasn't
it hasn't it is in my opinion it is
still cells it it all the way up to and
including nine months yes okay so why is
it no longer cells at nine months one
day if it's porn because um what makes
it go from cells to a human being I
guess those were and I'm sana gotcha it
seems like if you're so eager and
willing to end the life of another human
being it'd be pretty important for you
to define what a human being is it has
not had a connection with another human
being and it you can still feel love for
that let's say creature or human being
inside someone else why would we say
creature because human beings give birth
to non-human being babies do humans give
birth to fish dogs I'm just not gonna
like you always a multi cellular
cellular organism inside the womb
basically I'm just gonna which just
looks and sounds and fully functions
like a human being yes you just don't
want to call it a human being yes and
you're okay with the boarding a human
being all the way up to nine months let
me ask you this since she just said
until they take their first breath this
is the survived abortion bill um I'm
sure you probably heard from Governor
North and this is the entire DNC
platform everyone running for president
where they actually voted against it
where if a baby is born and has survived
an abortion so this is even after your
point which i think is pretty extreme
yeah I think even most pro-choice people
here wouldn't be okay with abortions up
to nine months but what about after a
baby is born
let's say has it has difficulty
breathing then it's alive okay even if
it can't breathe if it's on like I was
born and I had difficulty breathing
mm-hmm so why wasn't it okay to abort
you because my parents didn't want to
but if they wanted to that would be okay
yeah all right well I'm not convinced
okay Bree should I just think that's an
extreme example but I appreciate you
being completely honest okay I just
don't think you know I was hoping we can
find some common ground but if you think
your parents can abort you after you're
born just because I feel like it you
know good good good luck
[Music]
Oh what's your name
Aaron nice nice to meet you so I'm
pretty simple today I'm pro-life across
the board obviously with the great okay
so okay well I see your hostile right
there you just said I'm going to take
you on and you seem a little upset what
is it about my position that you've czar
that you cuz you're talking about the
legality of it it's not just your
opinion on it right
no I'm talking about the morality of it
okay well it's my own body mm-hmm I'm a
woman if I don't have though don't want
to give birth abortion to me is just
like forced miscarriage mm-hmm to you
yeah so that's that's a great opinion so
I'm trying to convince you right but
that is an opinion what if it's not your
body if it's not my body it's not my
business okay so if that baby inside
your woman's not your body
it's an autonomous human being mm-hmm
think you know the right to kill it
why do you know the right to I need
anyone else penis is not conscious it's
not especially since legally yet you
can't abort up to nine months it's when
the first trimester oh you can yeah you
can't legally yeah that's stupid
well we find some common ground there
yes agree with Andrew before you well I
mean up to nine months that baby's about
to pop I think it would be fine if that
baby you know was about to die in the
first few minutes there's no point
anyways mm-hmm so but this is something
that happens a lot people bring up an
extreme example like rape incest or the
baby's about to die to make a point
sounds to me like you support abortion
regardless yeah okay so let's not even
know that doesn't matter so much I guess
what it comes down to is what do you
define as personhood you said it's my
body my choice but if there's a baby
inside of you that is in fact not your
body it's not your daddy okay
how so yeah because it's my blood like
that child is half my blood so if
someone if someone gets a blood if you
give a blood transfusion to someone else
do you know on their body DNA man it's
actually genetics yeah you know do you
know one new genetic DNA is formed a
whole new genetic code so you could give
blood to you and
be my son no no what I'm saying is that
at the moment of conception there's
entirely new DNA formed not your DNA not
the father's DNA its DNA of an entirely
new human being that defines everything
from eye color to height to male pattern
baldness
but it's still half my DNA that went
into it
sure yeah so then by that logic as long
as it's a portion of your game it would
be okay to abort a nine month old child
a two-year-old child because it's your
DNA
how can you abort a two-year-old child
kill it it's not the same well I'm just
trying to understand what you define as
personhood and what gives you the right
to terminate a life that isn't your own
you're saying because a portion of it is
your DNA yes experience
okay consciousness yes okay so you
believe what determines personhood is
consciousness a child is not gonna know
anything I just want to make sure we
understand here um yeah let me allow you
to how do you define a person a human
being what makes us people what makes us
human what makes us human yeah what's
your experience like just like I said
earlier it's the experience okay we're
all friggin humans we're all made up of
the same kind of DNA you know you look
at you and you look at me we're both
human cool but what makes us a person in
her personhood is our own experiences
okay no need to versus nurture all that
psychology sure yeah so well if someone
let's say has Alzheimer's dementia or
someone who's born with severe brain
damage or doesn't have functioning limbs
they're not necessarily entirely
conscious of the world around them
they're not able to develop
relationships does that make them not a
person not a human being no I'm I'm
going by the definition of consciousness
if someone is unconscious they cease to
be a person can you kill them no why not
because it's unconscious it's not
experience what if someone has never had
any experiences I've known people who
work with people special needs who are
not able to experience the outside world
we thought we use a term Oh No spectrum
and day by day experienced every hour
every minute okay they experienced that
okay it's not just in a personal things
it's not just I mean
even if somebody had wasn't able to
experience the world couldn't leave
their home they still experienced what
it was like to eat what it was like to
drink what it was like to I don't know
read a book see the TV look outside the
window experience pain yes a beating
heart hearing the mother's voice mm-hmm
would these not count as human
experiences oh yeah it does okay so then
it's a human that you're killing mm-hmm
and you're okay with it that hasn't had
any experience we just agreed that those
are experiences yeah but that child
doesn't retain any of that it's well
neither does a one-year-old neither does
a two month old baby so I'm trying to
get to the point when does it become
okay to end a life but what point is
there enough retention of memory for it
to be okay for you to kill them that's
that other living being
when it's not born when it's not born
yeah okay so here we go so now we're
talking about location a person ceases
to be a person depending on location
inside or outside the womb so it seems
to me that you would support abortion up
to nine months if it was necessary yeah
not if it was necessary going by the
definition of personhood according to
your own logic man that's just semantics
no it's not you thought yeah it is you
just said use it up until it's born yeah
it's not a person so then what's the
problem with aborting a baby up to nine
months then earlier you said that
wouldn't be okay it's not a person it
depends on the situation how so man no
I'm real I'm curious how so I'll tell
you want me to explain my position the
only consistent line of logic to define
what makes it when a human being is
formed is that conception because that's
what entirely new unique DNA is formed
mmm-hmm
consciousness isn't consistent as we've
as we've gone through viability as we
went to with Andrew is not a consistent
trail of logic and location you don't
cease to be a person if you're in that
library out of that library you don't
cease to be a person if you're in the
womb or seven inches outside okay I see
your point but that doesn't mean that I
shouldn't be able to get an abortion if
I it was so necessary it certainly does
it certainly does if we agree that
that's a person then you shouldn't be
able to take the life of another person
you can never take a life another person
you can wave your hand around as much as
you want right with your own body unless
it hits me in the face you can't take
the life of another human being sure I
can okay
we disagree I don't think you can kill
another human being okay I guess I
wasn't able to convince you know I I'm
really I'm compelled but I I don't
understand your consistency of logic
here you said you were against
nine-month-old abortions but then you
said well until it's worn it's not
really a person so now you just said
it's you think it's okay to kill another
human being as long as it's in the womb
you acknowledge it's a human being and
you think it's okay to kill it because
you want to that's not going to convince
me what would you what would you present
to convince me otherwise I guess well
you don't I mean we talked about those
extreme experiences that people have the
rape join eating to do all those things
I guess if you were in my shoes and you
were a broke college student who got
raped and you know was disowned by her
family because they were super religious
and they didn't accept that I like to
editorializing here but you're going I'm
just putting a story together okay then
you would be okay with bringing that
child into the world and not even be
able being able to provide for it not
being able to give it any kind of health
care of that child got sick it would die
anyways because they wouldn't get you
know vaccines what if that child
wouldn't get vaccines yeah okay so are
you asking me would I be okay with you
might not be able to afford health care
yeah yeah I don't agree with the premise
so two things first off you bring up an
extreme example to make a point
sounds to me like you don't really care
about rape or incest do you support
abortion anyway in the sense that it
doesn't matter to you as it relates to
abortion so if I were to agree to let's
say okay
in all cases of rape or incest abortion
for all would you agree with all of the
cases no abortion yeah you would yeah so
if there were only an exception for rape
and incest you would make but you would
agree that abortion on every
other instance would be immoral and
should be illegal no okay well then why
bring it up now as it relates to the
story that you're painting here with
religious parents who has communicate
you and don't help you because you've
gotten pregnant you've been raped
I think that's horrible I do think that
would be a horrible story and my heart
would go out to you would if you were in
that situation and yes it is an extreme
but to put you in that extreme yeah what
would you do
well I of course wouldn't abort the baby
so what would you do then after you've
given birth to the baby what would you
do
yeah I guess without abortion what
choices are present I support for other
choices
abstinence contraception motherhood
adoption in the case of rape a very very
small extreme example as we both
acknowledged you have motherhood or
adoption
mmm-hmm I just don't support the choice
that would involve killing a child I
think that's pretty consistent I think
you have a good opinion I guess if you
believe something I think it's important
to scientifically determine where a life
begins and I don't think that you've
given that much thought and I think
that's the crux of all of this if
obviously if we acknowledge that's a
human life but it seems as though you
have you're just okay with terminating
in people who are looking to make
headway with people who are pro-life
they would have to present some kind of
an argument that would true prove that
this is not a human being that's not a
person but when you say it is a person
it is a human being
I don't care anyway I have the right to
kill another human being as you've
presented yeah and I'm not gonna be on
board but I appreciate you sitting down
well there you have it another
installment of what I would consider
mostly productive discussions did
anything here surprised you were the
views more extreme more reasoned more
moderate let me know in the comments
below and stay tuned for the next
installment looking forward to seeing
you there
okay if you liked this video you know
you watch videos on YouTube a fiber
Jimmy Kimmel if I were Stephen Colbert
or Trevor Noah I would tell you to
subscribe but I have no corporate
overlords who demand that I do this
demeaning promo I do the demeaning promo
because I choose to subscribe or hit the
notification Bell because I need you I
need you please do it